the Xbox series X and S version of
Warhammer 40K dark tide has been delayed
as has the upcoming seasonal content
rollout for the game on Twitter develop
a fat shark released a statement
announcing the delay citing feedback
from the community as the reason for it
fat shark will Implement a complete
crafting system a more rewarding
progression loop as well as fine-tuning
the game's stability and performance
before bringing the title to console and
releasing new content addressing all
this before introducing the game to more
players is probably for the best as dark
tide despite its flaws has been
generally well received in gamespot's
Warhammer 40K dark tide PC review Mark
Delaney wrote quote dark tide is both a
promising left for dead like and a
flawed live service but its issues are
fixable and the growth of vermintide
suggests that dark tide will also enjoy
a long shelf life as one of the better
games of its kind if you're on Xbox and
need something too dark tide you over
until dark Tides release how about
revisiting a blast from the past as a
surprise GoldenEye is coming to Game
Pass before the end of the month the
upres version of the game will drop on
the service Friday January 27th
GoldenEye W7 originally came out on
Nintendo 64 in 1997 and was based on the
1995 movie starring Pierce Brosnan the
important caveat to remember however is
this updated version of the game will
feature online multiplayer on Nintendo's
switch but not on Xbox instead the James
Bond title will have achievements split
screen multiplayer and a 4K resolution
on Microsoft's console Nintendo switch
online plus expansion pack costs 50 per
year and is the only way to play
GoldenEye on that system the game will
be available through Xbox game pass but
also become a part of rare replay on
Xbox that means you won't need to
subscribe to a service necessarily to
play in Microsoft's ecosystem we'll see
how the 25 year old old game holds up
today when it drops at the end of the
week but in 1997 Jeff gerstmann said in
gamespot's review quote GoldenEye not
only lives up to the quality not
quantity Mantra that Nintendo continues
to tout it surpasses it we might all be
Jeff's age by the time highly
anticipated the days before releases as
the game pushed back its launch for
March of this year to November but many
online are starting to feel uneasy about
the game as a whole the post-apocalyptic
zombie game which has been criticized
for its reported use of unpaid workers
has been delayed to November 2023 due in
part to a trademark issue developer
fantastic and publisher mitona said in a
statement that Steen blocked the day
before from getting a page on the store
due to a request from a private
individual of The Game's name the studio
said when it announced the day before in
January 2021 the name the day before was
available to trademark as a video game
after this a person registered that name
of the U.S patent and trademark offers
beating fantastic to the punch the
studio went on to say it had planned to
release a quote lengthy gameplay video
for the day before in January but the
video now won't be released until the
studio can quote sort this issue out the
video will be posted ASAP the studio
said stating that lawyers have to
approve its release the game has a lot
of hype behind it already as the day
before was for a period of time steam's
most wishlisted game but the fact that
fantastic has never released a video
game that the developer refers to its
workers as volunteers and now this
bizarre trademark issue have
anticipating players on edge were you
planning to jump into dark tide on Xbox
are you going to jump back into or the
GoldenEye Shenanigans to take you back
to that wonderful year that was 1997.
let us know in the comments and we'll
see you here for more Gamespot news
[Music]